[Music]
I'm just gonna briefly say a couple of
things about obesity here then we're
going to open this up for questions for
a few moments obesity is a disease of
deficiency it's not a disease of excess
obesity is not a disease of excess
that's why nobody's been able to solve
the problem because everybody views it
as a disease of excess it's a deficiency
disease the symptom of the deficiency
disease these special minerals the
minerals deficiencies caused a special
symptom called the munchies and so
instead of giving you these minerals
medical doctors invented the snack food
industry hmm that's the treatment for
the munchies is snack foods next
so Hell's Kitchen is the book for
diabetes for obesity for the metabolic
syndrome we got plenty of those out
there Hell's Kitchen you know we call it
a Hell's Kitchen because the kitchen in
your home can be a place of heaven or a
place a hell depending on how you cook I
mean you can kill somebody you can
purposely murder them all you got to do
is get them out with everything to eat
fried foods fried foods for breakfast
lunch and dinner you'll walk okay next
the Paleo diet which is just essentially
meat and vegetables no grains way to me
doctors say the whole grains are good
you mean the ones that live to be 56
okay go on
next well if that tells the story next
next next next No yeah look at that
next look at that
next next next ok Patrick dule wait a
thousand 72 pounds da my stomach bypass
they put him on a calorie restricted
diet and he lost 462 pounds over a
two-year period
this is him leaving the hospital to go
home when he got home he died BAM he
just drops dead because when you're
obese fat is not the disease fat is just
a symptom of disease just like when you
have diabetes high blood sugars a
symptom Azis when you have a high blood
pressure high blood pressure is just to
the symptom of disease being overweight
and obese is just a symptom of the
disease which is a mineral deficiency
the mineral deficiency will still kill
you you all know somebody who's lost 50
pounds 100 - Bob Francine did such a
good job she lost all that weight and
then she went and died next this gal
here she had two Guinness World Book of
Records Rose Lee Bradford she had two
Guinness World Book arrived very famous
lady won number one her first Guinness
World Book of Records she was the
heaviest woman ever weighed and she
weighed 1,200 pounds officially by
Ginsburg local records you went on two
dates with Rosalee you had a ton and a
quarter of fun
and there her second Guinness World Book
record she officially lost 736 pounds
and then she died because the doctors
failed to understand that the weight was
not the problem was just the symptom of
the disease okay are you getting it now
okay
the mighty 90 will prevent you from
being overweight if you're overweight
you take the mighty nine and you throw
what we call the slender FX weight
management program to it and the weight
just goes away healthfully you stay on
those things you never gain the weight
back you'll add 25 to 50 health years
your life is that simple okay next next
next next Oh back up 144 percent of our
kids under the age of 15 of all races
look like that today that's because they
are minerally deficient it has nothing
to do with too many video games are too
much television or too much texting and
all that kind of stuff it's a mineral
deficiency disease next-next see
everybody wants to think this is a cause
of obesity this is this the symptom of
the cause of obesity it's not the
positive obeah is the symptom of the
cause of it next this young fella here
from south carolina 14 years old weigh
five hundred and fifty-five pounds they
put the mother in jail and they took him
away from the mother they should have
put the pediatrician in jail because she
went to him every year say my kid is 200
pounds overweight my kids 300 pounds
overweight she kept going to the
pediatrician he said make him exercise
they should have put the pediatrician in
jail not the mother okay next Loyola
University in Chicago came out in August
of 2009 and said exercise won't help you
lose weight in fact it makes you
hungrier because when you sweat from
exercise you're not losing just water
but a soup that contains all these
minerals and you lose all these minerals
you just get hungrier
okay so now you take that money but you
have to take it appropriate for body
weight somebody who weighs a hundred
pounds will take one-third the amount of
somebody who takes 300 pounds because it
goes one dose 400 pounds of body weight
okay is by body weight
you want to come to me and say well I've
been taking it for 14 months and
nothing's happening okay we weighed 200
pounds how much you take might take a
thimbleful faithfully every day
okay well that won't work okay